Republicans are set to pass the enormous
tax cut bill President Trump delivers a
new national security strategy and a
major backlash to meats who begins
brought on by some very weird columns
I'll tell you all about him I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the bench Bureau Show
all righty so a lot to get to today of
course the Republicans are set to vote
in the House and the Senate today on the
revised to tax bill the tax bill would
reduce the corporate tax rate from 35%
all the way down to 21%
all the rest of it is is important but
not nearly as important is that central
premise there will be reductions in the
individual tax rates but the heart of
this tax bill is the reduction of the
corporate tax rate I'll tell you all
about it and why the media are beside
themselves over it and does this mean a
revaluation of president Trump's
presidency in the first year so far
we'll talk about all that but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at the u.s. CCA so gun was gone
lovers listen up how would you like to
head to the range tomorrow with a brand
new gun I would well I know that my
friends the u.s. DC I would like you to
do so as well
they want to make sure that responsible
gun owning Americans are able to get
their hands on better firearms and so
they are ending 2017 by giving you up to
17 chances to win your new gun daily
that's right a different gun every
single day of the week it could be a
Kimber it could be a Glock it could be a
Springfield all you have to do is go to
defend my family now three.com let's
defend my family now the digit 3 dot-com
to reveal which gun you could be taking
home tomorrow
remember there's not a lot of time to
register the gun of the day will always
disappear at midnight and this will be
the last time I am telling you the
website so again it is defend my family
now three.com defend my family now three
the digit 3 calm to reveal today's gun
from the US ECA and enter to win you
could win a new gun every single day
this week but this is your last chance
defend my family now three.com that is
defend my family now free.com you should
register with us CC anyway they have a
bunch of fantastic services and they
help you with not only background
knowledge about how to use weapon but
what happens if you have to use a weapon
and you need legal help defend my family
now 3com that can save your chances to
win a brand-new gun every single day
which is pretty awesome so check that
out again defend my family now three.com
okay so today is the big tax cut day oh
yes today it now seems that the
Republican tax cut is going to sort
through conference it is not a popular
tax cut that is not particularly
surprising the medium been all over this
tax cut from beginning to end the 50% of
the American population thinks that
their taxes are going to increase
because of this bill that's patently
insane
80% of individual taxpayers will see a
tax decrease because of this bill I'm
actually in the
20 percent I would vote for the bill
anyway the reason I'm in the other 20%
is I am a high income earner in a blue
state with high state income taxes but
the vast majority of Americans are going
to see a significant tax decrease the
average American will see a tax decrease
of or the average tax decrease will be
something like $2,000 which is not
insignificant and in terms of corporate
tax rate every country that has ever
dramatically lowered its corporate tax
rate that I am aware of has seen a
significant fiscal boost immediately
afterward this was true in Spain it was
true in Denmark it's been true
throughout Europe it's been true in
Germany in the United States we have the
highest corporate tax rate of any
industrialized country we have a lower
individual tax rates but higher
corporate tax rates that's quite foolish
we should be lowering the corporate tax
rate that's what this bill does I'm sort
of astonished that so many Republicans
have failed to make the case for
lowering the corporate tax rate on a
regular basis they've been focused
solely on the idea that individuals have
to have their tax rates reduced
maybe it's because Republicans don't
have the brains or the moral wherewithal
to explain that corporations are really
just ways that we organize with each
other legally so that we can do business
in more efficient fashion if you lower
the tax rate on those organizations
you're essentially lowering the tax rate
on individuals if I wish that we had the
brains to explain that apparently we
don't so it's more unpopular than it is
popular but people see more money in
their pocket always ends up being
popular if you look back at the Reagan
tax bill of 1981 that was not
particularly popular at the time it
became very popular shortly thereafter
when people realized they were getting
more of their own money back so even
kind of wavering Republicans are now on
board Senator Tom cotton had planted in
this bill a repeal of the individual
mandate under Obamacare that's a good
thing it's a bad thing it's a very good
thing because it is the least popular
provision of Obamacare so it's a
political win for President Trump and
for the Republicans to get rid of the
individual mandate remember the
individual mandate under Obamacare is
what forces you to buy health insurance
the bad news is that's going to increase
prices in the individual market because
it was the mandate that was forcing
people like me to pay in the individual
market young people to pay in the
individual market that was keeping the
prices down for older sick people in the
individual market those are now set to
rise pretty dramatically Congress is
gonna have to come in and fill the gap
which apparently they're doing through
the Alexander it's I believe it's the
Alexander Marie Bell in the in the
United States Senate so weirdly enough
the Republicans in the ten
government are shockingly growing
government but as an achievement for
President Trump it's pretty great he's
gonna get to claim that he repealed
Obamacare or at least the individual
mandate he's gonna get to claim that he
decreased taxes and Republicans are
betting that the effects of this bill
will be positive enough that it will
impact them positively in 2018 and let's
see the flip side you know the flip side
is they don't pass anything this year
and this year is basically a total dud
as far as legislation despite Republican
control of the Senate the house in the
White House that would be completely
unacceptable so even wavering
Republicans around board Susan Collins
no conservative Halcyon she says that
she supports the conference agreement
that's about to go through I rise to
express my support for the conference
agreement on the tax cuts and Jobbik
the first major overhaul of our tax code
since 1986 this legislation will provide
tax relief to working families encourage
the creation of jobs right here in
America and spur economic growth that
will benefit all Americans okay so you
know even when susan collins on board
that means that you have a broad
consensus of republicans who are on
board this is a good thing obviously and
it's very good for president Trump
there's a reason the Democrats were
trying desperately to stop it they might
have been smarter to actually embrace
parts of this tax plan instead they're
not going to do so Bernie Sanders the
socialist he says that they did
everything they could to stop the tax
bill this looks like it's going to get
passed through the Senate in the house
and signed by the president this tax cut
bill is there anything more that
opponents like you could have done to
stop this well I think we did everything
that we could but at the end of the day
what you had is people like mr. minuchin
who himself is worth three or four
hundred million dollars are the
President of the United States who is
worth several billion dollars as you
mentioned some four or five thousand
lobbyists doing everything that they
could to write a bill which
significantly benefits the wealthiest
people in this country and the largest
corporations this is one of my chief
irritations about how Democrats play
this I wish there
publicans would just say the truth the
reason that you are seeing
disproportionate shares of the tax cut
go to people at the upper end of the
income bracket is because those people
are paying a disproportionate share of
the taxes okay the reason that rich
people are going to get more of a tax
break is because they are paying more of
the taxes okay in terms of net taxes the
amount of tax dollars that rich people
are getting in the country ninety five
percent of all federal spending on net
is paid for by the top income bracket
the top twenty percent quintile of the
American population the top one percent
are paying something like 50 percent of
all federal income taxes in the nation
of course they're going to see a
disproportionate share of the tax cut
you can't give a tax cut to people who
aren't paying taxes it's astonishing to
me that the Republicans refuse to say
this it's astonishing to me the
Republicans refuse to pick the case for
a corporate tax cut and there is a very
strong case for a corporate tax cut but
regardless the policies going to pass
and we're gonna see how it plays out in
the Senate and this is leading to some
recasting of the Trump administration's
entire first year a lot of people who've
been a highly skeptical of Trump are now
going back and revising their opinion of
how his first year went now so I think
that it's been a golden first year I
don't think it's been a golden first
year so I think that President Trump has
governed a lot more conservative than we
had any right to expect as conservatives
from his campaign there the answer is
yes I think that a lot of people hoped
he would govern as conservative as he's
governed but he has governed extremely
conservative in this has been the most
conservative first year of an
administration certainly since Ronald
Reagan it's probably more conservative
than george w bush's first year when
george w bush by a recall correctly was
already pushing campaign finance reform
at this point but you know Trump's tried
that doesn't mean a lot it's gotten done
there's been a lot of incompetence there
been there's been a lot of battery
Trump's approval ratings at 35% that is
by far the lowest approval rating for
any president at this point in American
history at this point even Ronald Reagan
who was unpopular during his first year
had a 49 percent approval rating but
there's no question that Trump has
governed a lot more conservative than I
thought he was going to right I was
wrong about Trump on Gorsuch and I
thought that based on the evidence there
was not a lot of evidence that who's
gonna govern this conservative
once he got into office and if you
recall the early indicators are that he
was not going to do that right Steve
Bannon was pushing the idea of an
infrastructure bill first thing out of
the gate and then people were talking
about an isolationist foreign policy
none of that has happened instead
President Trump has basically championed
what is a fairly typical
in tax cut he has cut regulations in a
way that I love he is pursued foreign
policy in a way that is much more
hawkish than I think his campaign led on
all of that is very good and I'm gonna
go through all that in a second Trump
you know he he it is it is a day of good
Trump bad Trump I mean we end the first
year and we're getting close to the end
of the year here and it has been a very
good Trump bad Trump years it's a
construct that I created last year
during the election cycle saying that
the problem with Trump is that when he's
good he's really good when he's bad he's
really bad it's been a very good from
bad Trump kind of year so in honor of
that I think that we so in honor of that
we're gonna do a little bit of good
Trump bad Trump coming up in just a few
minutes here because there's a lot going
on right between the tax cuts and his
national security announcements there's
a lot happening here but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
Skillshare so are you interested in
making your resume better if you're
interested in earning more if you're
interested in having a longer lasting
career if you're interested in
broadening and deepening your skillset
that is what Skillshare is for with over
three million members and more than
17,000 classes skill share is the
Netflix for online learning take class
and graphic designs yes a lot of
photography social media marketing
that's what I'm taking digital
illustration much more these classes are
taught by industry experts at all about
45 minutes long self-contained the tough
I experience professionals they are
perfect if you're looking to build your
career or start the side hustle of your
dreams you have an obligation to
yourself and your family to continue
increasing your skills and we don't live
40 years ago when you can just have the
same skill set for 40 years and maintain
your job that's not the way it works
anymore your skill set has to be getting
better all the time and that is what
skill share is for it's why people at my
company are taking skills share classes
on a regular basis skills share right
now is giving my listeners a one-month
free trial of unlimited access to over
17,000 classes go to WWC I'll share comm
slash appear oh that skill shared comma
slash Shapiro to start your free month
today that skill shared comm slash
Shapiro to start your free month today
and again you get that one-month free
trial 17,000 classes once you're hooked
you're gonna be hooked I mean you're
gonna want more of those skills to added
your resume Skillshare comm slash repair
I'll start that free month today and
it's not all you know just skillsets
it's also fun stuff you know hand
lettering calligraphy and watercolor and
all sorts of fun stuff you can get so
Skillshare dot-com slash appear I use
that slash capiro so they know that we
set you okay so
Trump tweets out today that he's very
happy about the tax bill here is what he
tweeted so he tweeted quote stocks and
the economy have a long way to go after
the tax cut bill is totally understood
and appreciated in scope and size
immediate expensing will have a big
impact biggest tax cuts in a format ever
passed enjoy and create many beautiful
jobs you know yeah yeah I love the guy
with it with the beautiful jobs all caps
this this is the thing about Trump and
this is what's so puzzling to me about
his presidency is that President Trump's
policies as I say have been largely
conservative and I say largely I mean
almost entirely very conservative and
yet he's really unpopular and he is the
president who of all presidents should
best understand marketing right I mean
this guy is the marketing guru he's the
marketing guru of all time he
transformed what is by any measure a
dicey real-estate Empire into television
fame and fortune and then that into the
presidency and yet he doesn't seem to
know how to Wed positive rhetoric and
useful rhetoric to an agenda that has
been very positive for Americans thus
far me I was looking at a list of his
accomplishments today and the list is is
sizable I mean if you look at what
they've done in the White House it's not
nothing you know it's not it's not
everything it's not like they've done
tons of stuff through Congress they
haven't this has not been as productive
of first year as for example Barack
Obama's first year but if you look at
all the things that Trump is actually
done he's done some pretty good things I
mean I made a list of these things this
morning and I've been trying I mean I
know that folks who listen to the show
know I've tried to be as fair to Trump
as humanly possible so here's just some
of the stuff that Trump has done in year
1 so Justice Gorsuch obviously big win
for president Trump did a feat of Isis
we've talked about on the program the
media basically ignored it Isis grew
under President Obama who called it the
JV squad Isis has now reverted to being
basically another my Isis has basically
been cut all the way down to size
I mean that in territorial terms they've
been reduced to virtually nothing and
he's done all of that without having to
oust Bashar Assad maybe you should ask
Bashar Assad but that's a different
issue as many of us have been saying for
a long time and the stock market under
President Trump has soared 5,000 points
this year yeah that I don't think that's
always a great measure of a president it
soared under Barack Obama - but yeah he
does get credit he's the one in the
white house there's been excellent
growth and the unemployment statistics
are very strong under President Trump I
think that's largely due to the market
understanding and knowing that Trump is
not a threat to their business that
Trump is not somebody who's trying to
Retin their business he has cut
regulations at a twenty two to one ratio
for every new regulation added 22 have
been cut right curbing the Iran the olia
President Trump declared that Iran had
been decertified under the deal which
paves the way for new sanctions he
should be pushing for further sanctions
but he's also been pushing for an anti
Iran alliance that has been
extraordinarily powerful and has
reshaped the region a lot of that is the
unintended result of President Obama's
attempts to make around a regional power
but Saudi Arabia Egypt Jordan is rather
now in a de facto alliance he announced
Jerusalem is Israel's capital obviously
he started to open public lands the
federal government has seized vast
swaths of the West nearly all of Nevada
is federal territory a lot of that land
ought to be returned to the people for
their use President Trump is moving
along those lines he passed the new
sanctions against North Korea now listen
he hasn't solved the North Korean
problem but frankly who could I don't
see a real solution there and unless you
know something I don't
the best he's going to be able to do is
pass those new sanctions which he did
they're gonna repeal the individual
mandate as I discussed tax reform as I
discussed a record number of appellate
court appointments so they've he's
nominated and approved 12 appellate
court judges which is more than any
other president in history in his first
year he pulled that from the Paris
Accords the travel ban was finally
approved by the courts whose botched
originally in pretty bad fashion but
it's now been approved by the Supreme
Court
he's unshackled the military he's
changed the rules of engagement he
stopped tripping on the police which is
something the President Obama was very
fond of was ripping on the police and
every available opportunities done a lot
of very good things right and this is
the problem for President Trump in the
good Trump bad from construct there's so
much good there really is there's a lot
of good the question is why can't it all
be good why does there have to be bad
Trump because when you look at the bad
Trump list most of the bad Trump list is
about things that he's failed to do
picks that he's made in his
administration and stupid stuff that he
said well maybe if you didn't say stupid
stuff and pick bad people for his
administration he'd been able to get
more good stuff done a disciplined
president Trump is the best president
Trump okay president Trump has been more
disciplined over the last three weeks he
has look at his Twitter feed it's been a
lot less rabid than usual we haven't
gotten a lot of the random fights with
Lavar ball we haven't gotten as much of
the I'm ripping on the NFL now you know
if you look at Trump's failures they've
largely been driven by his mouth and if
you would get from successes they've
largely been driven by his
administration
and if you would just let his
administration do their job I've been
saying this literally since the
beginning of his administration he's
picked some very good people to do their
job if he would just shut up and let
them do their job everything would be
much better so you know let's play the
good Trump bad from song because this is
an ultimate good Trump bad Trump episode
do we have that
[Music]
so as you know I just named a bunch of
good Trump right and Trump is pumped
about the tax bill all of that is very
good all of the things that Trump is a
problem about are things that do make a
difference as president now I know the
tendency for conservatives is to just
say okay you know the president says
what the president says and who cares
just ignore it and be grateful for what
you got but the problem is that if you
look back at the Obama administration I
was there he the most damaging things
that President Obama did were not on
policy they were tearing Americans apart
from one another they were destroying
American unity through the use of his
rhetoric through the promulgation of his
worldview that's the stuff that
presidents are really remembered for
right you remember a president for maybe
two legislative accomplishments maybe
right what do you remember Ronald Reagan
for you remember Ronald Reagan for tax
cuts basically and taking down the
Soviet Union that's it right that's all
that we remember about Ronald Reagan
Bill Clinton what do you remember him
for you really remember him for the tax
increases and then the tax decreases and
then the impeachment right that's pretty
much what you remember Bill Clinton for
and maybe his crime though he remembered
George W Bush for his tax cuts and the
water rock right those are basically the
things that you remember George W Bush
for what you'd but what you remember
about each of these presidents is how
they change the American culture in deep
and abiding ways right that's how you
remember the presidents what you really
remember about Clinton is not his
legislative accomplishments what you
remember about Bill Clinton is that he
was somebody who totally disconnected
honor from the office of the presidency
well you remember about Ronald Reagan
was the morning and American optimism of
the of the Reagan administration well
you remember about Nixon was Watergate
and the idea that the president's he was
corrupt well you remember about Jimmy
Carter was generalized feelings of
incompetence in the presidency which led
to the rise of Reagan what you remember
about George W Bush was the notion of an
honorable guy who didn't know how to
defend himself if you're a Republican
and a liar and a cheat if you're a
Democrat if you remember Barack Obama
what you see is as a Democrat is a guy
who finally made America come to terms
with racial conflicts you're on the
right well you see about Barack Obama is
a man who deliberately used race as a
polarizing issue in America Taron
American from American fighting class
and race war and making
intersectionality a chief plank in the
Democratic platform right that's what we
remember so when we say about Trump look
at all the great things he's doing
ignore his rhetoric you can't ignore
what the president says what the
president says has a major impact so
we've talked about all the good Trump
now for a little bit of bad
okay so here's a perfect example
yesterday there's an Amtrak derailment
right and this terrible terrible story
over it to come to Washington over the
i-5 there is a bridge the Amtrak
derailed right over the bridge and fell
over six people at least had been killed
77 people were wounded apparently and it
was a brand new it was a brand new track
right the track is brand new this is
like its first run and apparently there
was an object on the track and that's
what you reeled the train now the real
solution here by the way is to defund
Amtrak right Amtrak is is not a
profitable thing it's it's a waste of
money the literally the only profitable
part of Amtrak that believes the Acela
corridor but put that aside president
Trump's first reaction here should not
have been to go to policy right we
didn't like him when Obama did it but
here's what Trump tweeted out
nonetheless right here's what Trump said
nonetheless he said that we have to fix
infrastructure because of Amtrak let me
begin by expressing our deepest
sympathies and most heartfelt prayers
for the victims of the train derailment
in Washington State we are closely
monitoring the situation and
coordinating with local authorities it
is all the more reason why we must start
immediately fixing the infrastructure of
the United States right that's bad from
because the idea that he has to jump
immediately the policy poisons the well
there's a time when Americans should
should be responding to the tragedy not
be not calling for infrastructure fixes
and it turns out we don't need an
infrastructure fix we literally just
built that rail five seconds ago and
this has been the pattern for Trump
right for every Justice Gorsuch there's
a Charlottesville for every for every
tax bill there is a Mike Flynn and Steve
Bennett right this is the problem for
Trump the general last impression of
Trump over the first year is what's
damaging Republicans not his policies
now what Democrats are gonna try and do
is conflate his policies with this
generalized impression of failure
they're going to say that he's unpopular
because of the tax cuts or because of
Justice Gorsuch or because he's cutting
regulations that is not true he's
unpopular despite those things
he's unpopular because President Trump
says dumb things on a regular basis and
if you'd stop saying dumb things on a
regular basis if somebody just unplugged
his phone and he couldn't use Twitter
for two weeks
his approval rating would go up by 10
points in two weeks I promise you he'd
be up in the mid-40s immediately if he
just shut up alright cuz if you look at
the list of the big
who's that he's made virtually all of
them rhetorical right charlottesville
being the most obvious example when he
went out there and said both sides were
responsible and then he suggested a
moral equivalence between the people who
are protesting at Reynoldsville and the
people who were actually the the white
supremacists instigators and suggested
that there were good people at
Charlottesville this is the problem for
President Trump if you look at the list
of his failures you know the Mike Flynn
the firing James call me the overall
revering the fake news stuff the Lamar
Ball stuff the fights at the NFL right
all of that stuff is stuff that is
stoppable that's why we are so close to
having a dream administration really but
that's going to require President Trump
to control himself and I don't know that
it's basically wants him to control
himself it seems to me that many in the
base are more interested in Trump doing
the NFL stuff than passing the tax cuts
they're more excited about the culture
war aspect of Trump than they are about
the policy side I am precisely the
opposite well in a second I want to
discuss back to good Trump what Trump
had to say about foreign policy because
Trump gave a big speech on national on
the new national security strategy they
rolled out yesterday and what's funny
about Trump's national security strategy
what's really fascinating about this
particular national security strategy is
something that is common to virtually
all of Trump's speeches and all of
trumps rhetoric on foreign policy Trump
says one thing and then he implements
bushing and foreign policy now let's be
real about this president Trump's
foreign policy is very very similar to
george w bush's foreign policy it's
basically neoconservative in a lot of
ways during the campaign there's every
indicator he looks more like Rand Paul
or Ron Paul than he did like George W
Bush but an implementation his foreign
policy has looked a lot more like George
W Bush than like Rand
or Ron Paul the isolationist sentiments
that he mailed during the campaign have
not materialized in real life and so
whenever you listen to one of his
foreign policy speeches while you
actually see is a disconnect write him
kind of preaching the Ron Paul line or
the Rand Paul line and then when he
actually talks policy him embracing the
idea of a powerful muscular America in
the world making sure that our
principles are upheld and strengthening
alliances through greater military
firepower
I mean basically he's embraced
Reaganesque foreign policy while
pretending to be a pat buchanan it--
which is a really interesting combo not
particularly honest one but it's
interesting so Trump gives his big
national security strategy speech
yesterday he begins with what
I think it's a dubious premise he talked
about how the American people are the
source of American greatness you'll see
why he does this in a second throughout
our history the American people have
always been the true source of American
greatness our people have promoted
culture and promoted our values
Americans have fought and sacrificed on
the battlefields all over the world we
have liberated captive nations
transformed former enemies into the best
of friends and lifted entire regions of
the planet from poverty to prosperity
because of our people America has been
among the greatest forces for peace and
justice and the history of the world the
American people are generous you are
determined you're brave you are strong
and you're wise
he said he finishes the resting when the
American people speak all of us should
listen and they spoke in November 2016
they love me right so I am the American
people is basically the message here the
reason the Trump is doing this is
because this is one of those disconnects
right Trump doesn't want to say that the
American creed is what makes us great it
is ok to the American creed it's not the
American people there is a distinction
the reason that I say this is because
the idea that the American people make
us great well that's like saying the
Greek people make us great what's
different genetically about an American
then about a Greek well not much because
a Greek can become an American right
what's genetically different between an
Englishman and an American the answer is
not much right what makes America great
is the central principles that we uphold
so far as the American people hold those
principles that makes us great but it's
not the people themselves right it's not
that it's not that we're better people
than other people around the world
that's just silly
but you know the reason that he's saying
that is because as soon as you start
talking about greater principles that
America holds then you have to talk
about how we promulgate this president
principles and now we're back in
neoconservative land right now we're
back in Bush Reagan land we're no longer
in Pat Buchanan land so again this is
one of these weird gaps in Trump's kind
of thinking and you'll see it here too
here he talks about and you hear this
sort of Buchanan desk note about
isolationism he talks about you know in
the past we've worried about
nation-building but now we're bringing
people home our leaders engaged in
nation building abroad while they fail
to build up and replenish our nation at
home they undercut and shortchanged our
men and women in uniform with inadequate
resources unstable funding and unclear
missions they fail to insist that our
often very wealthy allies pay their fair
share for defense putting a massive and
unfair burden on the US taxpayer and our
great US military they neglected a
nuclear medicine North Korea made a
disastrous week and incomprehensibly bad
deal with Iran and allow terrorists such
as Isis to gain control of vast parts of
territory all across the Middle East
okay so the first couple sentences here
I'm no bearing on the last couple
sentences so what he's talking about
here in the end is exactly right you
know they ignore North Korea that they
allow ron's who run roughshod over the
Middle East that they allowed Isis to
grow all of that's true but the only way
to fight that is with a more muscular
American military so he's right about
funding the American military when he
says our leaders engaged in nation
building abroad but they failed to build
up and replenish our nation at home
right that statement right there is pure
Rand Paul and Ron Paul and then he
proceeds to immediately swivel and say
we need to be more involved in foreign
policy right this is something that he
says repeatedly in other words the
fruits of his of his foreign policy have
been directly opposed to the
isolationist sentiments that he espoused
on the campaign trail and then he
continues to quasi espoused sometimes
during his speeches it's not the end of
the world but I just want to point out
the inconsistency because what I don't
want is for people to attribute the
winds of his foreign policy to the
isolationist foreign policy that he
seems to be espousing publicly sometimes
right the fact is Trump is winning
foreign policy victories he's just doing
it in the name of an ideology that he's
not actually upholding in practice so he
Trump is right when he says that he's
won a big victory over Isis in the
Middle East this is obviously true it is
worth noting here he did continue
Obama's foreign policy on Isis he just
strengthened it but he gets credit for
doing that following my trip to the
Middle East
Gulf states and other muslim-majority
nations joined together to fight radical
Islamist ideology and terrorist
financing we have dealt Isis one
devastating defeat after another the
coalition to defeat Isis has now
recaptured almost 100 percent of the
land once held by these terrorists in
Iraq and in Syria great job great job
really good thank you
thank you we have a great military we're
now chasing them wherever they flee and
we will not let them into the United
States okay good for Trump right this is
the foreign policy that he's pursuing
and I'm glad that there's a disconnect
between what he was saying on the
campaign trail and what he's doing in
practice this I thought was the best
part of his speech he talked about what
it is here he really does talk about
what his priorities aren't his
priorities are quite good right here he
talks about optimism and confidence
optimism has surged confidence has
returned with this new confidence we are
also bringing back clarity to our
thinking we are reasserting these
fundamental truths a nation without
borders is not a nation
a nation that does not protect
prosperity at home cannot protect its
interests abroad a nation that is not
prepared to win a war is a nation not
capable of preventing a war a nation
that is not proud of its history cannot
be confident in its future and a nation
that is not certain of its values cannot
summon the will to defend them right
okay this is the actual statement of the
term policy and this is what you should
focus on and this is quite good right
the idea that we have to be proud of
what America is proud of our history
proud of our principles that will make
America great again so listen Trump is a
vast difference in kind from the Obama
administration on foreign policy for
that he deserves all the credit in the
world I just want to see more of the
rhetoric like the end of the speech and
less like the isolationist beginning of
the speech okay so meanwhile there is a
backlash that is building against the
me2 movement backlash it has really
begun based on the Miche movement now
making clear that there is no standard
for even such basic things as consent
now I talked about this a few weeks ago
on the show and a little bit of flak for
it I said that one of the problems with
left-wing social ideology is that they
proclaim that consent is the only value
when it comes to sex but then they
refuse to abide by those rules when they
when the chips are on the table what I
meant by that is that the left doesn't
actually believe that yes means yes or
no means no right the left wants to say
that consent is the only thing that
matters listen I believe consent is
deeply deeply deeply important but the
idea that consent is is a clear yes or
no line there's no malleability to it at
all that is just not practical in terms
of human sexual relationships no does
mean no but yes doesn't all me always
mean yes and what's interesting is that
the left is beginning to recognize this
but they don't know how to deal with
this and they also don't know how to set
a standard for what should end a career
and what you're not Matt Damon is being
raked over the coals today because he
had the temerity to suggest that sexual
harassment is not the same as sexual
assault that saying something mean to a
woman is not the same as Harvey
Weinstein raping them and the left is
just going after him hammer and tongs
well how dare he they're all bad yes
they're all bad but a pickpocket doesn't
get punished the same way as a mass
murderer that's just that silly doesn't
not make
lyta pickpockets is somebody who is a
car thief doesn't get treated the same
as a serial killer but they're both bad
but but the left refuses to acknowledge
these distinctions what's funny is even
the left is beginning to realize this
now of course in order for the left to
realize that their ox has to be gored a
lot of what the left is doing now is
largely because al franken is on his way
out of the Senate and they're sad about
that they feel like they wish they
hadn't gotten rid of him mika brzezinski
finally sounding off on me too and she
says guys we may have gone a little too
far here where any accusation by anyone
at any time can Road a man's career
yeah we've been saying this for a while
hear me though the process itself is
what we need to be talking about before
we talk about the men because the
process needs to be it's gonna be
complicated but I think women feel that
they are maligned and mistreated through
the process and therefore they're afraid
to step forward so we need to look at
the process but right now any woman can
say anything and a man's career is
ruined now a lot of women can say things
that are true and their career should be
ruined by the problem but any woman can
say anything and that's it it's over
okay so she's exactly right Matt Damon
is being raked over the coals for
basically saying the same thing maker
Brzezinski did he didn't interview a
business insider and here's what he said
quote we're in this watershed moment and
it's great but I think one thing that's
not being talked about is there are a
whole bleep load of guys the
preponderance of men I've worked with
who don't do this kind of thing whose
lives aren't gonna be affected when he
was asked if he'd ever worked with
someone who's been accused of sexual
misconduct he said would have to be on a
case-by-case basis
he said that always went into my
thinking I mean I wouldn't want to work
with somebody who life's too short for
that but the question of if somebody had
allegations against them you know it
would be a case-by-case basis you go
what's the story here
and then he also said there's a
difference between you know patting
someone on the butt and rape or child
molestation right well there is I mean
I'm sorry to break it to folks but there
is they both want to be punished but the
punishment ought not be the same said
both of these behaviors need to be
confronted and eradicated without
question but they shouldn't be conflated
right tell me what he's saying wrong
here I mean I'm not a Matt Damon
defender I think Matt Dave
is not exactly the brightest tag in the
basket but what Rose McGowan said Matt
Damon is dense Zerlina Maxwell says Matt
Damon equals every white man who is used
to people taking his opinion seriously
even if he has no idea what the hell
he's talking about I mean this is just
it like really I love this Cher says
Matt Damon is the epitome of a faux a
life whose performative locus is more
about servicing his own ego than the
needs of the oppressed and
disenfranchised and we have gone okay
this is insane
Matt Damon didn't say anything wrong
there I mean again I'm defending Matt
Damon here Matt Damon didn't do anything
wrong here and then meanwhile there is
no standard for behavior so here is the
evidence there's no standard for
behavior so over the weekend there's a
woman named Jessica Bennett Jessica
Bennett is the gender editor of the New
York Times yes that's a real thing
there's a gender editor which is weird I
don't know how you would edit a gender
but in any case she wrote a piece titled
when saying yes is easier than saying no
she argued that in many cases women say
yes to sex but they don't actually want
to say yes to sex and she says quote
sometimes yes means no simply because it
is easier to go through with it then
explain our way out of the situation
sometimes no means yes because you
actually do want to do it but you know
you're supposed to you're not supposed
to lest you be labeled to
and if you're a man that no often means
to just try harder because you know
persuasion is part of the game and it
continued and she argued that consent is
actually societally to find that our
idea of what we want of our own desire
is linked to what we think we're
supposed to on this is what Bennett
rights but Bennett offers no clear
solution on this right so now she's
saying that sometimes yes doesn't
actually means yes sometimes yes means
no and sometimes no means yes meaning a
woman doesn't want to have sex or she
doesn't want to have sex but she wants
to be persuaded into it she's playing
hard to get
okay this has happened I'm sure to
thousands of people over the years
millions of people where woman says no
and then a guy says please and the girl
says okay sounds great like this the
idea that that no means no permanently
obviously is not true the idea that no
means no for a minute-to-minute is not
always true you have to take no as a no
guys but this is when you don't have any
societal standards when sex has been
completely delinked from meaning it's
difficult to redraw these lines and this
is one of the problems that in the me2
moment we're trying to draw lines in an
area where all lines have blendable
obliterate it right bet it doesn't offer
any clear solutions if it's true that
women say yes but me no are men supposed
to read minds if a woman says no but a
man seduces her until she says yes is
the initial no more important than the
final yes
now Bennet doesn't offer any guidance
here but she's not the only one saying
this there's a woman named Rebecca Reed
for the Metro who said she once
participated in a threesome because she
didn't want to be rude she was over at
dinner with a guy and his wife and they
said come upstairs and she was like well
you know I had dinner I guess I don't
want to ruin the dinner oh really how
are they supposed to know that you're
not into it I mean like I've been in a
lot of weird dinner parties but I would
never just say yes to having sex of
people out of a desire not to be rude
why well Reid says such experiences
aren't uncommon quote there are hundreds
of reasons why but they all boil down to
the same thing we're nice girls we've
been raised to be nice it's so funny how
this definition has changed right fifty
years ago if you said a girl was a nice
girl and then she didn't put out right
means everything this is what it meant
if you go back to 1955 and you said that
girl is a nice girl with his men this
was a euphemism for she wants to remain
a virgin until she is married now a nice
girl means that you're supposed to say
yes to any sexual propositions otherwise
are being mean she says quote sometimes
being careful means having sex you don't
want that leaves you feeling dirty and
sad and a bit icky it's not rape it's
not abuse but it's not nice either but
now we're gonna conflate rape abuse and
not niceness apparently in the pages of
The New Yorker there's this short story
that went viral okay it's called
cat person the author of this of this
piece it has now patent apparently a
million dollar advance because the piece
went so viral what exactly is the piece
one's about a woman named Margo who
seduces a man she sends him all the
signals that she wants to have sex with
him but she's internally divided over
whether to go through that quote she
knew that her last chance of enjoying
this encounter had disappeared but she
would carry through with it until it was
over in the end she has sex with the guy
right she goes ahead with it even though
she's sort of repulsed by it and it's
not really rape because she says yes the
whole way but then she doesn't like it
and then she breaks up with the guy he
like she never contacts him again and
he's texting with her and then he says
that she's a and the whole idea of
this short story she's not really a
because she didn't really want to
go through with it but you went through
with it to be nice and now he's being
mean because he's calling her a
and there is this sort of vagary in
sexual relationships and this is painful
stuff I'm sure for a lot of women but it
does raise a pretty serious question
what about the
what are men supposed to do because it's
men who are on the line here right if
these women have a bad sexual experience
that is quite terrible it's quite awful
I feel terrible for them but if the
suggestion is to go to bed the bad
sexual experience and I get to ruin a
guy's career over it or ruin his life
over it there I'm not so cool right we
are in the midst of a crusade not to
make women feel better about sex but to
punish male aggressors right there is a
distinction this is not about making
women feel better about sex than me -
movement was not supposed to be about
just all sexual experiences for women
are supposed to be glorious and
wonderful because not all sexual
experiences are going to be Laureus and
wonderful I'm married for 10 years not
all sex sexual experiences even within
marriage are the same right sometimes
better than others the idea that as a
society we are now targeting bad men we
have to we have to differentiate between
the two goals one is sure that sex for
women is better the other is assured
that men are not aggressors the second
one seems to be easier than the first
but we're conflating the two if we can
if we water consent down to nothingness
if yes sometimes means no and no
sometimes means yes and men are supposed
to read minds and if they don't read
minds properly we ruin their careers
then how can we ever expect there to be
any sort of comfortable sex at all
because men are not going to engage if
they're bright right and women are then
going to claim that men are denying them
I suppose what we have here is a problem
of expectations okay all three of these
articles to talk about yes not meaning
yes and no not meaning no all the time
they're articulating a complaint that
women want to fulfill men's expectations
basically they're blaming men for their
own confusion over sex right men expect
them to have sex they don't want to
disappoint the men they have sex with
them men want them to have sex they may
or may not want to have sex they start
it and then they feel like it's too much
of a bother not to move away from sex
but there's another expectation that's
been created here that's not about men
at all okay there's two expectations one
is that men want to have sex with you
all the time that's not an expectation
that's a reality okay men want to have
sex with women all the time at least
straight men but there's a second
expectation that women are fulfilling
and this is the one that's actually
destroying a lot of the rules okay that
is the expectation that women themselves
are supposed to treat sex casually or
they are reinforcing the patriarchy this
is the feminist argument that if a woman
is an old-fashioned nice girl but if a
woman says I don't want to have sex
until I'm married because I find that
to be a perversion of nature and a
movement away from what God intended for
us this makes her a prude
it makes her backwards watch any
Hollywood movie made for the last 30
years the good girl is really the stupid
girl
the good girl is the dimwit who's going
to have to loosen up a little bit right
in Footloose the good girl is really she
she wants to be a bad girl but she's
repressed by John Lithgow right this is
the Society Hollywood is created for us
then the society the feminist movement
is created for us there are two
expectations men always had the
expectation or the hope not the
expectation let's play this way men
always had the hope that women would
randomly have sex with them now men have
the expectation that women will randomly
have sex with them what changed
it wasn't men it wasn't men what changed
here what changed here was that the
feminist movement said to women that you
have a responsibility to treat sex
casually otherwise you are falling in
line with a patriarchy the patriarchal
system our consent only society in which
sexual activity has become a throwaway
and any notion of cherishing and a
scoffed is patriarchal we laugh at that
as patriarchal men have developed
expectations women are moving to meet
those expectations it's not good for men
it's not good for women it's not good
for anyone I consent only manners in a
system where people are capable of
saying no when I'm saying that society
is basically telling women on all sides
to say yes and then they're telling men
that it's okay if women say yes unless
women actually meant no okay that's a
mess of its own making okay well we're
gonna have to break there before we go
any further go over and subscribe $9.99
a month gets you subscription to daily
we're calm when you get that
subscription you get the rest of our
show live you get the rest of the they
get the rest of Andrew Clayton's show
live there are some Michael Knowles is
show live you get to be part of our
mailbag great get to ask me questions
and have them answer all of this makes
your life more awesome plus if you get
the annual subscription you get the very
best in all beverage vessels it was so
valuable I couldn't even bring it with
me down here to Florida where I'm at the
teepee USA conference I couldn't even
afford to bring it in my carry-on
because I wouldn't I treasure it so much
my leftist here is hot or called tumblr
he had dad for a 99 a 99 dollar annual
subscription fee plus the Shapiro store
is coming in the new year and that will
be exciting and get discounts there if
you want to subscribe if you want to
just listen to the show later on audio
look at iTunes SoundCloud Google Play
stitch or any of the any of the normal
any of the
podcasting apps or you can go to our
YouTube channel and subscribe over there
we have a Christmas video that is coming
out in the very near future I think
that's coming out later this week
actually so look out for that we are the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so time for some of things I like
some things I hate and then we'll
deconstruct culture for a hot second
okay so things that I like after last
week you remember I played a clip of Roy
Moore riding in on a horse - the song
from Blazing Saddles and that got me
thinking what are some great movies that
have title songs or songs involved that
are that are just hilarious so the first
one that pops mind is a movie I grew up
with when I was a kid I loved this movie
growing up I haven't seen it for
probably 25 years and I'm only 33 so
last time I saw is probably eight or
nine it's Kirk Douglas and Burt
Lancaster and gunfight at the OK Corral
Frankie laine sings the song same guy
was saying the Blazing Saddles song and
it's got this classic just Western trope
of the singer who actually takes you
through the story like he narrates the
story it's like a The Ballad of Sweeney
Todd and Sweeney Todd so that the movie
is gunfight at the OK Corral it's a it's
a really underrated film that actually
does hold up really well as directed by
the great John Sturges take a look at
this this old Western because it's
pretty great ok around
okay Koran there the outlaw band made
their final stand old game
[Music]
Burt Lancaster as the famous Wyatt Earp
Kirk Douglas as the notorious Doc
Holliday two men as different as day and
night yet fate linked them together
through the violent years get going down
the Backstairs much obliged marshal the
in Dodge City and thank you properly you
can thank me properly by staying out of
Dodge City Rhonda Fleming as Laura Dembo
right golden cleanup tombstone
there's a hundred tombstones on the
frontier all crying for the great Wyatt
Earp clean them all up
Joe Van Fleet as Cape Fisher let me tell
you something Doc Holliday all them
fancy clothes and that smart talk of
yours don't make you no gentleman you
are dirt just like me
John Ireland as Ringo not ready have a
drink then now you'll see them as they
really were hot-blooded men in a row and
it's great I mean it's classic western
Kirk Douglas apparently you know he's
trying to play Doc Holliday who has
consumption and apparently they shot all
the scenes out of order and to one of
the things that he did is he would time
his coughs seen the scene so that it
looked like he was getting progressively
sicker as the film went on which works
in the movie it's a good performance by
Kirk Douglas who is we may have to do a
week before at Douglas movies at some
point but worth watching and holds up
pretty well it's not as good movies
tombstone of course but it is a good
movie and it's a classic Western okay um
one other thing that I like so you see
all these headlines that are constantly
coming out for the mainstream media IDF
IDF is the Israeli Defence Force is
arresting children they're arresting
these poor hungry Palestinian urchins
it's just terrible
okay here's what's actually going on the
Palestinians put up kids to try and
assault Israeli soldiers to get them
arrested for the cameras here are some
tape of IDF soldiers and what they're
actually going through what they have to
do what you see here is a bunch of kids
walking up to Israeli soldiers trying to
grab them trying to harass them trying
to push them and one one walks up and
slaps an Israeli soldier in the face
another punches an Israeli soldier in
the face and the soldiers are just
standing there taking it right they're
just standing there taking it these are
these are kids from probably 11 or 12
years old they've been told by their
parents that they need to go over and
harass the Israeli soldiers get
themselves arrested so they walk over
and look at these Raley's soldiers
trying to ignore them are the Israeli
soldiers trying to stay away from them
because they don't want to get in a
confrontation with these kids and
they're literally smacking these Israeli
soldiers in the face and eventually the
Israeli soldiers are forced to arrest
them because you can only slap a law
enforcement officer a thousand times
before he's going to arrest you for all
these people who say the Israeli
soldiers are out to shoot people okay
there's not a cop in the United States
who'd stand for this kind of crap
there's not a soldier in the American
army who'd stand for this kind of crap
maybe they would in Iraq or Afghanistan
but you know the IDF is doing this every
day the idea the idea for the bad guys
here is just insane okay time for a
quick thing
I hate and then we'll deconstruct
culture for a second so things I hate
okay so here is say Hillary Clinton the
left just can't let it go
and so the Daily Show did something
called the song for women and Hillary
Clinton makes a cameo in The Daily
Show's that song for women yes this is a
natural thing here we go ladies hit that
refrain oh no we're not doing that
trying to help you know young Hillary
Clinton take a palm
[Applause]
[Music]
keeping it
hello to Clinton speaking for all women
except for the ones her husband's raped
the fact that you keep trying to keep
Hillary relevant is an amazing thing
Hillary eventually will become as much
of a joke as Al Gore has become every
time you see him you laugh there's a
reason for that okay another quick thing
that I hate so people are making a very
big deal out of this one story that's
now going around the internet about
apparently an unidentified flying object
that appeared in front of a Navy pilot
and then jet it off incredibly quickly
do you have video of that
so this is kind of like an oblong shaped
what looks like a UFO it's rotated and
then apparently it like flies away and
you know twice the speed of light you
know it just moves away really quickly
and people are saying well this means
the aliens are here okay if the aliens
were here either they're prepping for an
attack in which case we should all be
scared out of our minds and this should
be the top of the news or there is
something that we just don't understand
going on and it's not aliens because of
aliens were to come here they probably
make their presence known also if they
have technology that superior to
anything that we have then presumably
they would move on us because this is
apparently been going on for years
but maybe I'm wrong maybe we'll find out
later that this was the beginning of the
invasion and I ignored it and I'm you
know one of the bad guys okay time for
deconstructing the culture so there's a
song that has now become unpopular okay
and they've changed the lyrics to it
because it's unpopular it was a
Christmas favorite because baby it's
cold outside and we've been informed by
the left that this song is rapey oh yes
the song baby it's cold outside is rape
and play a little bit of it and then I'm
gonna play you some modern top 40 and
you tell me which is more rapey
[Music]
it's cold outside baby it's cold outside
semen is big open that you drop down
hold your hands there just like man
start here
okay so this is a creepy version the
Michael Buble did with idina menzel with
little kids but the original version
with I think it's there's like Louis
Armstrong and I think it's Billie
Holiday in any case the lyric that
people go crazy about is that there is a
there's the woman is basically
protesting that she has to leave but she
doesn't really want to leave and then
she asks at one point what's in this
drink right she said it says the
neighbors might think say what's in this
drink and so it sounds like he's date
raping her
yeah that's not what's happening okay
the whole point is that she's feeling
buzzed and she's feeling happy and she's
feeling flirty and she doesn't want to
leave and he's trying to convince her to
stay whit's rapey no it's called a
rather typical seduction you know
assuming that the Dean Martin didn't
actually roofie anybody this is uh the
idea that this is date rape is is
ridiculous or that it's a rapey song
maybe there's nothing wrong with the
song is that possible then nobody who
listened to that thought oh baby it's
cold outside means I get to rape chicks
maybe that's it maybe that's a thing
what's hilarious is that all the same
people who say that that baby it's cold
outside it's a rapey song are fine with
top 40 music which is like the most
rapey music of all time
half the music is about some guys saying
I'm gonna jump on that Fang right I'm
gonna jump on her and I'm gonna do what
I want with her and the girls saying
yeah that's great you know that's what
I'm into like first of all half a let's
put this way if all of the lyrics to top
40 music were actually applied in real
life by men to women these would not be
good pickup lines
okay these would be really rapey pick-up
lines so there's a there's a song out
right now called Habana and there's part
where there is a rap interlude which has
become a staple of top 40 music and it's
horrifying
in any case this is one of the rappers
rapping a little bit you tell me which
is more rapey maybe it's called outsider
this
[Music]
understand what the hell he's saying but
here is what he is saying okay what
Jeffrey is saying is quote just
graduated fresh on campus fresh out East
Atlanta with no manners damn fresh out
East Atlanta bump on her bumper like a
traffic jam now I miss the part where
she said yes to the bumping on her
bumper like a traffic jam but that seems
a little rape you know this hey I was
quick to pay that girl like Uncle Sam so
now he's paying her for the sex good job
back it on me shawty Craven on me get to
digging on me she waited on me shawty
kickin on me got the bacon on me I don't
even what the hell this means this is
history in the making on me
Point Blank close range Daffy if it cost
a million that's me I was getting moola
man they feel me yeah clearly that's not
rapey at all what's more rapey as a guy
saying to a girl stay inside with me and
begging her to stay inside with him and
her finally saying yes clearly that's
the Raby problem here our society may be
screwed up beyond all repair i'm mad or
sexual at least until there's a return
to traditional notions of male and
female and what men want and what women
want and standards where we can
accommodate both okay so we'll be back
here tomorrow I'll see you then I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the venture Bureau show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Glover executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex zingaro audio is mixed by
Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by Jael
para the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire for word publishing production
copyright ford publishing 2017